Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Now, it may only be a myth, and it is certainly not medical science, but there is a popular theory that a man who cannot whistle has homosexual tendencies. M hadn't whistled since he was a boy, unconsciously his mouth pursed, and a clear note was emitted. That was Ian Fleming in Man with the Golden Gun. Bond novel, of course, written in 1965.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及我们备受欢迎的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。好了，这或许只是个传说，当然也绝非医学科学，但民间有一种广为流传的说法：不会吹口哨的男人具有同性恋倾向。M 从男孩时期起就再没吹过口哨，下意识地，他的嘴唇噘了起来，吹出一个清晰的音符。那是伊恩·弗莱明（Ian Fleming）在《金枪人》（Man with the Golden Gun）中的描写。当然，这是邦德系列小说，写于 1965 年。
And with me is massive James Bond fan Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic, we are doing this episode on James Bond because the new Daniel Craig film No Time to Die is out this week do you imagine that that's the kind of dialogue we'll be getting I thought you're going to ask me to whistle yeah well go on I'm not going to whistle I mean I feel like it's a lose-lose whatever whatever I do I think it's very bad for the reputation of this podcast if we start whistling in an attempt to prove our sexuality one way or the other um yes so it's it's a funny thing isn't it that um the bond phenomenon has endured so long and i'm sure we'll go on to talk lots about its historic significance and what it means about britishness and so on but actually if you go back to the books there's so much cancelable
和我一同录节目的是詹姆斯·邦德（James Bond）的超级粉丝多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。多米尼克，我们之所以做这期关于詹姆斯·邦德的节目，是因为丹尼尔·克雷格（Daniel Craig）的新片《无暇赴死》（No Time to Die）本周上映了。你觉得我们等会儿也会听到那种对话吗？我还以为你要让我吹口哨呢。对，好吧，来一个。我才不吹口哨呢。我是说，我觉得这左右都是输，无论我做什么，我都觉得，如果我们为了证明自己的性取向而开始吹口哨，不管是哪种取向，这对本播客的声誉来说都是极其糟糕的。嗯，对，所以这是一件很有趣的事，不是吗？嗯，邦德这种文化现象居然能持续这么久，而且我相信我们接下来还会深入探讨它的历史意义，以及它对“英国性”等概念意味着什么。但事实上，如果你回顾原著小说，里面有太多可以被“取消”的
material i'm gonna i'm gonna put my hand up and say i've never read one you've never read a bond book i've never read one but i have i don't need to because i've read you on it right your fine book the great british dream factory the strange history of our national imagination you have a fabulous chapter on it and also i've read simon winder's book um well he's my editor um it's it'sestuous. Bond, the man who saved Britain or whatever. Yeah, hilarious, hilarious. It's very funny and it's full of fantastic quotations, so I don't think I actually need to have read the novels.
素材了。我，我得举手承认，我从来没读过一本。你从来没读过邦德的书？我一本都没读过。但我，我不需要读，因为我读过你写的内容啊，对吧？你在你那本优秀的著作《伟大英国造梦工厂：我们国家想象力的奇异历史》（The Great British Dream Factory: The Strange History of Our National Imagination）中，有一个非常精彩的章节专门讲这个；而且我还读过西蒙·温德（Simon Winder）的书，嗯，他是我的编辑——这可真沾亲带故啊。《拯救英国的男人邦德》（Bond, the Man who Saved Britain）或者别的什么。对，太搞笑了，太逗了。这本书非常有趣，里面引用的名言警句也妙趣横生，所以我其实觉得没必要去读原著小说了。
But I will say that the quotations in the novels, well, goodness. Yeah, it's quite strong stuff, isn't it? So we did a podcast, Tom, on Sherlock Holmes. So we've done one on a fictional character already and this is our second one on a purely fictional character and I think um they make a nice pair actually because in in their different ways Holmes and Bond are both representatives of Britain and Britishness but they're also fascinating historical phenomena so Holmes is obviously sort of late Victorian Edwardian Britain and Bond is a creation of well the, the post-World War II, 1950s, 1960s.
不过我要说的是，小说里的那些引言，天哪。是啊，尺度相当大，对吧？所以汤姆，我们之前做过一期关于夏洛克·福尔摩斯的播客。所以我们已经做过一期关于虚构人物的节目了，而这是我们第二期纯粹围绕虚构人物展开的节目。我觉得，嗯，他俩其实是一对很好的搭档，因为福尔摩斯和邦德在各自不同的方式下，既是英国和“英国性”的代表，同时也是迷人的历史现象。所以，福尔摩斯显然代表了晚期维多利亚时代和爱德华时代的英国，而邦德则是——怎么说呢——战后 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代的产物。
But compared to Holmes, I mean, there's so much in Bond that just kind of, well, reeks of his age, I guess. I mean, the attitudes to race, to sexuality, to all kinds of things are by our standards. It's only a few decades on, but it seems like a completely different age, whereas Holmes, oddly, seems a much more contemporary character. Yeah, I think that's true. And I think that's partly because
但与福尔摩斯相比，我的意思是，邦德身上有很多东西简直就是，嗯，散发着那个时代陈腐的气息，我想是的。我是说，对待种族、对待性以及各种事物的态度，按我们现在的标准来看——虽然仅仅过了几十年，但它看起来就像是一个完全不同的时代。相比之下，奇怪的是，福尔摩斯似乎是一个更具现代感的角色。是的，我想确实如此。而且我认为部分原因在于
Ian Fleming was reactionary even by the standards of the 1950s. I mean, he was intensely reactionary. And even at the time, some people sort of remarked on that, and there's a very famous review. So for people who don't like James Bond, they'll enjoy this. This was Paul Johnson in The New Statesman in 1958.
伊恩·弗莱明即便以 20 世纪 50 年代的标准来看也是个极端保守派。我是说，他极其保守。甚至在当时，有些人就对此有所评论，其中有一篇非常著名的书评——所以对于那些不喜欢詹姆斯·邦德的人来说，你们会喜欢这段的——这是保罗·约翰逊（Paul Johnson）1958 年在《新政治家》（The New Statesman）杂志上写的。
So he's just been reading Dr. No, and he says, I've just finished what is without any doubt the nastiest book I've ever read. I had to suppress a strong impulse to throw the thing away. There are three basic ingredients in Dr. No, all unhealthy, all thoroughly English. The sadism of a schoolboy bully, the mechanical two-dimensional sex longings of a frustrated adolescent, and the crude snob cravings of a suburban adult. Mr. Fleming has no literary skill, and this seems to me far more dangerous than straight pornography. The novel is badly written to the point of incoherence and that sort of stuff about snobbery sexism and sadism
他当时刚读完《诺博士》（Dr. No），于是他写道：“我刚读完毫无疑问是我读过的最恶劣的书。我不得不强行压抑住把这东西扔掉的强烈冲动。《诺博士》包含三个基本成分，全都不健康，全都是彻头彻尾的英国式的。那就是：学校恶霸的虐待狂倾向、受挫青少年的机械化二维性渴望，以及郊区成年人粗俗势利的贪婪。弗莱明先生毫无文学技巧，在我看来，这比纯粹的黄色作品还要危险得多。这部小说的文笔烂到近乎语无伦次。”诸如此类关于势利、性别歧视和虐待狂的言论，
i mean they're what we bond fans love about James Bond is it though but well i think they're very important elements of it actually there's a huge chasm, isn't there, between the novels and the films? Because I was the Roger Moore generation. Yeah. And to me, it seemed pretty much on a level with Carry On. I mean, it seemed about as sadistic as a Carry On film, i.e. not very. It was kind of smutty. And that was about the limit of it.
我的意思是，这些正是我们邦德迷热爱詹姆斯·邦德的原因，难道不是吗？不过，嗯，我认为这些确实是非常重要的元素。事实上，小说和电影之间存在着巨大的鸿沟，不是吗？因为我是罗杰·摩尔（Roger Moore）那一代人。是的。对我来说，它似乎和《滑稽戏》（Carry On）系列电影差不多在一个水平线上。我的意思是，它展现出的虐待狂倾向大概也就跟《滑稽戏》电影差不多，也就是说——几乎没有。它有点下流，而这也差不多就是它的极限了。
That's all you see in it, the smut. Yeah. So I think because of that, I've never really... I mean, I never felt... I've never really taken James Bond seriously. I mean, he seems about as serious as Kenneth Williams. Well, I think the Roger Moore films, which people of our age probably take as the template, are to some extent aberrations within the sequence.
你在里面看到的就只有那些下流。是的。所以我想正因如此，我从来没有真正……我是说，我从来没觉得……我从来没把詹姆斯·邦德当回事。我的意思是，他看起来严肃的程度大概也就跟肯尼斯·威廉姆斯（Kenneth Williams）差不多。嗯，我觉得罗杰·摩尔的电影——我们这个年纪的人大概把它们当作了模版——在整个系列中在某种程度上属于变异之作。
So there are more non-roger moore's than there are roger moore's before and after um and the roger moore's are not representative in any way of fleming's vision um now obviously they work as kind of parodies to some extent they're parodies of themselves yeah um so they're kind of austin powers before austin powers they are austin powers but that's one they're kind of austin powers before austin powers they are austin powers but that's one of the things why i don't think austin powers is quite as funny as lots of other people think because it's parodying something that was already parodying yeah itself um but i think well i mean maybe if you're a skeptic i need to persuade you that
所以在罗杰·摩尔之前和之后，非罗杰·摩尔的电影其实更多；而且罗杰·摩尔的版本在任何方面都不能代表弗莱明的构想。嗯，当然，它们在某种程度上作为恶搞作品是成功的——它们是对自身的恶搞，对吧？嗯，所以它们有点像《王牌大贱谍》（Austin Powers）出现之前的《王牌大贱谍》。它们就是《王牌大贱谍》。但这也是为什么我觉得《王牌大贱谍》其实没有其他人想象的那么搞笑的原因之一，因为它在恶搞一个本来就已经在恶搞自身的。对。不过我想，好吧，也许如果你是个怀疑论者，我需要说服你相信
james no i'm not a skeptic i'm not a skeptic but but because i grew up with um the roger moore one and then because basically the only other ones i've seen are the um the more the daniel craig ones yeah he's kind of earnest and tortured yeah and basically i guess trying to square the original material with the very different cultural mores of the 21st century i hadn't properly realized kind of kind of what the novels were like and so they're quite strong stuff aren't they they are quite strong stuff and i mean the funny thing is i don't think it's brought out even more clearly in in the simon winder book than in in your book um so could we just look at Ian Fleming? Of course, yeah.
詹姆斯……不，我不是怀疑论者，我不是怀疑论者。但正因为我是伴随着，嗯，罗杰·摩尔的版本长大的，而且基本上我唯一看过的其他版本就是，嗯，丹尼尔·克雷格的版本，对吧？他那种严肃且备受折磨的形象，对吧？基本上，我想他是在试图将原著素材与 21 世纪截然不同的文化风气调和起来。我以前没有真正意识到，小说原来是这个样子的，所以它们的尺度相当大，对吧？它们的尺度确实相当大。而且有趣的是，我觉得西蒙·温德的书里把这一点挖掘得甚至比你的书还要透彻得多，嗯。所以我们能聊聊伊恩·弗莱明吗？当然可以，行。
So tell me about Ian Fleming and where this stuff is coming from. So Ian Fleming, he's a very strange man. I think it's fair to say. I can't say that. So he's born in 1908. His father's a Tory MP, Valentine Fleming. They're from a family that made a lot of money in Dut and they've moved south from Dundee originally in the Victorian period and become very rich. So
那么，跟我讲讲伊恩·弗莱明，以及这些东西到底是从哪里来的吧。好吧，伊恩·弗莱明是个非常奇怪的人，我觉得这样说很公允。我不能不说这个。所以他出生于 1908 年。他的父亲是一名保守党议员瓦伦丁·弗莱明（Valentine Fleming）。他们的家族在黄麻（Jute）生意中赚了巨资，最初在维多利亚时期从邓迪（Dundee）南迁，并变得非常富有。所以
his father is a Tory MP and a barrister and a merchant banker. And his father, Valentine, is killed in the First World War in Picardy in 1917. Churchill wrote an obituary of him that appeared in The Times. And Fleming, Ian, you know, what is he, nine or so when his father dies? And that obviously has a colossal impact on him. And he has a picture of his father and he's always trying to live up to his father's tremendous heroism. The other thing that Ian Fleming suffers from is he's a younger brother, his older brother, Peter.
他的父亲是一位保守党议员、大律师兼商业银行家。他的父亲瓦伦丁于 1917 年在第一次世界大战中的皮卡第（Picardy）阵亡。丘吉尔曾为他写过一篇讣告，发表在《泰晤士报》上。而弗莱明——伊恩——你懂的，他父亲去世时他大概九岁左右？这显然对他的心灵造成了巨大的冲击。他留着父亲的照片，并且总是在努力不辜负父亲那了不起的英雄主义。伊恩·弗莱明面临的另一个困境是，他是一个弟弟，他的哥哥叫彼得（Peter）。
So Peter Fleming is a far more impressive man in every way. He's kind of forgotten now. There's a great sort of tragedy in that everybody remembers Ian Fleming, but not Peter Fleming. Peter Fleming is a genuine hero and an adventurer. So he's married to Celia Johnson, the actress who's in Brief Encounter. So he's got a film star wife. He's famous because he goes on an expedition to find the explorer Percy Fawcett, who had gone on this expedition of his own to find the lost city of Zed in Brazil. Kind of El Dorado question. El Dorado.
所以彼得·弗莱明在各方面都是一个远比他更令人印象深刻的男人。他现在差不多快被遗忘了吧。这其中有一种巨大的悲剧感，那就是人人都记得伊恩·弗莱明，却没人记得彼得·弗莱明。彼得·弗莱明是一个真正的英雄和冒险家。他娶了曾出演《相见恨晚》（Brief Encounter）的女演员西莉亚·约翰逊（Celia Johnson）为妻。所以他有一个电影明星妻子。他之所以出名，是因为他曾远征去寻找探险家珀西·福西特（Percy Fawcett），后者曾孤身前往巴西寻找失落的“Z城”。有点像黄金国之谜。黄金国。
So Peter Fleming, when he's a young man, goes to try and find him. Doesn't find him, but writes a best-selling book called Brazilian Adventure, which is a kind of true story of this incredible journey. Then he writes another book about an incredible journey called um news from tartary so he's done an overland journey in the 1930s from peking to kashmir um through kind of china um over the himalayas all this sort of amazing and he's an amazing i learned um he he was um the first person to be richly cursed at a revived witch ceremony.
所以彼得·弗莱明在年轻时曾去试着寻找他。虽然没找到，但他写了一本名为《巴西冒险》（Brazilian Adventure）的畅销书，这是一本记录这段不可思议旅程的纪实故事。接着他又写了另一本关于奇妙旅程的书，名叫，嗯，《来自鞑靼的消息》（News from Tartary）。因此他在 20 世纪 30 年代进行了一次从北京到克什米尔的跨大陆旅行，嗯，穿过中国，翻越喜马拉雅山，所有这些都非常惊人。我还了解到，他，他，嗯……他是在一个复兴的巫术仪式上第一个遭到恶毒诅咒的人。
Which, according to Dr Robin Douglas, who told me this on Twitter, was carried out by a group of Oxford students while he was at Oxford and he was a member of the Bullingdon Club. He was a member of the Bullingdon Club, but the curse clearly didn't work because he had this tremendous life.
根据罗宾·道格拉斯博士（Dr. Robin Douglas）在推特上告诉我的说法，这个诅咒是他在牛津大学就读期间由一群牛津学生施加的，当时他是布灵顿俱乐部（Bullingdon Club）的成员。他曾是布灵顿俱乐部成员，但这个诅咒显然没有灵验，因为他过着如此精彩的一生。
But he didn't become a famous novelist. No, he didn't. Well, it's only because of Peter Fle fleming by the way that ian fleming becomes a novelist at all because his brother pulls strings for him so ian fleming has this father and this brother who are in their different ways kind of symbols of british pluck and daring do and stuff they are absolutely the and masculinity they're the men you would want to be and ian fleming himself is an utter failure and a dud so he goes to eton and he's not academic they put him in the army class at eton so that he can go to sandhurst but he goes to sandhurst and he's a failure he gets gonorrhea from a prostitute and has to pull out of um of sandhurst he applies for the foreign office and he fails the entrance exams he goes into
但他并没有成为著名的小说家。不，他没有。好吧，说到底，多亏了彼得·弗莱明，伊恩·弗莱明才得以成为一名小说家，因为他的哥哥动用人脉为他铺路。所以伊恩·弗莱明有这样一位父亲和这样一位哥哥，他们在各自的方面都是英国人果敢坚毅与大无畏精神的象征，他们绝对是。还有男子气概，他们就是你想成为的那种男人。而伊恩·弗莱明本人却是个彻头彻尾的失败者和平庸之辈。他去了伊顿公学，但学术上不行，学校把他分到了伊顿的“陆军班”（army class），好让他能考入桑赫斯特皇家军事学院。但他去了桑赫斯特后却是个失败者——他从妓女那里染上了淋病，不得不退出桑赫斯特。他申请加入外交部，结果入学考试不及格。他去搞
banking and he fails at that he tries to set up as a stockbroker like his i think his father or some of his family connections had and he fails at that um so he's just an utter and he's also quite foppish and he's not a man the weird thing about ian fleming so much of bond is a wish fulfillment because he's not a man's man. He's not a... He'd be worried about an inability to whistle. Yeah, he's a man. Yeah, he's your man who can't whistle. And if you see, Simon Windu in his book
银行业，结果也失败了。他尝试像他父亲或某些家族关系那样开办一家股票经纪公司，结果还是失败了。所以他简直是个完完全全的……而且他还相当矫揉造作，根本算不上一个男子汉。伊恩·弗莱明最诡异的地方在于，邦德这个角色很大程度上是一种愿望成真（wish fulfillment），因为他根本不是那种传统意义上的男子汉。他不是那种……他会因为自己不会吹口哨而焦虑。对，他就是那种男人。是的，他就是那个不会吹口哨的男人。如果你看看西蒙·温德在他的书中
has a very funny section about photographs of Ian Fleming. So Fleming often, in some of the sort of classic photos that are used, he's wreathed in smoke to make him look like a man of mystery. But if you look at the photos of him where he's not wreathed in smoke, he's just this sort of simpering Noel Coward fellow with a bow tie
有一个非常搞笑的章节，里面谈到了伊恩·弗莱明的一些照片。弗莱明在一些常用的经典照片中，常常烟雾缭绕，好让自己看起来像个神秘男子。但如果你看那些没有被烟雾环绕的照片，他其实就是一个谄媚的诺埃尔·科沃德（Noel Coward）式的人物，系着领结，
and a kind of massive cigarette holder. I mean, the cigarette holder is not hard. The cigarette holder just makes him look so camp. So he has this one moment in the Second World War where, through family connections again, he gets a job as the personal assistant to the Royal Navy Intelligence Chief, Rear Admiral John Godfrey. And he's basically M. He's like the real life M, the head of intelligence. And this is Fleming's kind of, you know, he's living the dream. So he's a bit of a pen pusher, really, although he does
还拿着一个巨大的烟嘴。我是说，那个烟嘴可一点都不硬核。那个烟嘴只会让他看起来极其脂粉气（camp）。所以在第二次世界大战期间，他有那么一段时间——同样是通过家族关系——得到了一个职位，担任英国皇家海军情报局长、海军少将约翰·戈弗雷（Rear Admiral John Godfrey）的私人助理。他基本上就是 M 的原型。他就像现实生活中的 M，情报部门的负责人。这就是弗莱明的某种，你知道的，他在过着梦想中的生活。所以他其实有点像个只会动笔杆子的文官，尽管他确实
plan commando raids and things. But obviously the war doesn't last very long. So then he has to get a proper job. He gets a job as sort of running the foreign correspondents of the Kemsley newspaper groups. That's the group that includes the Sunday Times. And as usual with Ian Fleming, because he's posh and because he's got all these connections, it's a very cushy job. So he can take off for two to three months every year in the winter and go off to his house that he's built in Jamaica called Goldeneye and basically it's when he's there that he decides
策划过突击队突袭之类的事情。但战争显然没有持续多久。因此，他不得不去找一份正经工作。他得到了一份管理凯姆斯利报业集团（Kemsley newspaper groups）海外通讯员的工作——也就是那个拥有《星期日泰晤士报》的报业集团。和伊恩·弗莱明的惯常经历一样，因为他有社会地位，而且人脉广阔，这是一份非常优厚惬意的工作。所以他每年冬天都可以休假两三个月，前往他在牙牙买加建造的名为“金眼”（Goldeneye）的房子。基本上，也就是在那里，他决定
one day I'm going to um I'm going to try and write a novel and he writes um Casino Royale he starts writing it in February 1952 and this. And this is classic Ian Fleming. He sends it to Jonathan Cape, and they don't think it's very good. And they're not tempted, you know, they're not really interested in publishing it. And basically, Peter Fleming, who's a much more successful man in every way, says to Jonathan Cape, no, no, you really must publish my brother's book. And they do. And Casino Royale is set in northern France. Yeah.
有一天，嗯，我要尝试写一部小说。于是他写了《皇家赌场》（Casino Royale），并于 1952 年 2 月开始动笔。而这。这就是典型的伊恩·弗莱明。他把书稿寄给乔纳森·卡佩出版公司（Jonathan Cape），但他们觉得写得不怎么样。他们并不为之所动，你知道的，对出版它并不怎么感兴趣。结果，各方面都成功得多的彼得·弗莱明对乔纳森·卡佩说：“不，不，你们真的必须出版我弟弟的书。”于是他们出版了。《皇家赌场》的故事背景设定在法国北部。是的。
So it's not very exotic at all. So it's not exotic at all, yeah. No, it's a place you go on an exchange or a sort of rubbish school trip now. But at the time, I suppose it's exotic. The Casino Royale Les Eaux, sort of Le Touquet type place. Because it's a product of austerity Britain.
所以一点也不异国情调，对吧？所以一点也不异国情调，是的。不，那地方现在是你去交流学习或者参加什么垃圾学校旅行才会去的地方。但在当时，我想它大概算得上异国情调吧。勒图凯（Le Touquet）那种类型的“皇家赌场”水疗小镇。因为它正是英国紧缩时期的产物。
And that's the Simon Winder thesis, isn't it? That James Bond is wish fulfilment, not just for Ian Fleming, but for a Britain that is staring into the abyss of its own decline. Yeah, I don't really, this is a terrible thing to say about my own editor that I don't really, I don't completely share his thesis um but i don't completely share his thesis because
这就是西蒙·温德的论点，对吧？詹姆斯·邦德不仅是伊恩·弗莱明的愿望成真，也是一个凝视着自身衰落深渊的英国的愿望成真。是的，我其实——对自己的编辑说这话可能不太好，但我其实并不完全赞同他的论点，嗯，我不完全赞同他的论点，因为
actually at first during the heyday of austerity the bond books aren't terribly successful it's actually much a bit later on in the sort of late 1950s early 1960s that the sales really take off and that's after austerity is gone but i I think, to me, the Bond books are clear, they're wish fulfilment on the part of Ian Fleming, because he's hankering after the Second World War. And he has this sort of, he's living out this weird fantasy life through the books of what he thinks a man should be. But you don't think that this is a fantasy that's shared by lots of people
事实上，在紧缩政策的全盛时期之初，邦德小说其实并没有那么受欢迎。直到稍晚一点，也就是 20 世纪 50 年代末到 60 年代初，销量才真正腾飞，而那时紧缩时期已经过去了。但我认为，在我看来，邦德小说很明显是伊恩·弗莱明个人的愿望成真，因为他一直在怀念第二次世界大战。他通过这些小说，过着一种奇特的幻想生活，演绎着他认为一个真正的男人应该成为的样子。难道你不认为这也是一种幻想，是被许多
who had enjoyed the war and who find that you know the post-war reality rather gray and drag possibly i think it's yes i think there's an element of nostalgia for the war certainly rob but i buy that more than i buy the argument that it's uh it's all about the loss of empire i don't really think that is it people in the forefront of people's minds not least because a lot of the the people reading the books are american um and they don't give a damn about the loss of the british empire i mean they're probably delighted by it um i think it's i think a lot of it is about you know in the post-war years there's a lot of sort of anxiety about you, what it is to be a man.
经历过战争、发现战后现实相当灰暗乏味的人所共同分享的幻想吗？有可能。是的，我认为其中确实包含对战争的怀旧之情，当然，罗伯。我赞同这一点，胜过赞同那种“这一切全是为了失去帝国”的论点。我不认为那是人们脑海中最核心的想法，尤其是因为阅读这些小说的很多人都是美国人，他们才不在乎大英帝国的丧失呢——他们可能还为此感到高兴呢。我认为很大程度上是因为，你知道的，在战后岁月里，人们对于“究竟什么是男人”有着许多焦虑。
Obviously, women are flooding into the workplace. Gender roles are changing. And Bond, you know, anybody who grew up in these years knows that James Bond represents a kind of a sort of mad fantasy of sort of masculine omnipotence. Okay, so the inspiration lies in Ian Fleming's own sense of inadequacy. But can we broaden it out a bit? There's a question from Atlee18 who asks, what was Fleming's inspiration for Bond? Some say it was partly based on his friend David Niven. Yeah.
显然，女性正大批涌入职场，性别角色正在发生变化。而邦德——任何在这些年里长大的人都知道，詹姆斯·邦德代表了一种关于男性全能的疯狂幻想。好吧，所以灵感来源于伊恩·弗莱明自身的不安全感。但我们能把范围稍微扩大一点吗？有一位名叫 Atlee18 的网友提问：弗莱明创作邦德的灵感来源于哪里？有人说部分取材于他的朋友大卫·尼文（David Niven）。是的。
Is that true? Well, it's a very weird thing that Ian Fleming, when he was asked, consistently suggested David Niven to play James Bond because David Niven had been, I think, a commando in the Second World War. So he's a very impressive man. But his screen persona is nothing like that at all. I mean, his screen persona is the cigarette holder, moustache, foppishness. I mean, basically a dressing gown in human form I think actually the real the inspirations for James Bond I mean to me
这是真的吗？嗯，非常奇怪的是，伊恩·弗莱明在被问及此事时，一直建议由大卫·尼文来扮演詹姆斯·邦德，因为大卫·尼文在二战期间好像曾是一名突击队员。所以他是一个非常了不起的男人。但他在银幕上的形象与此大相径庭。我是说，他在银幕上的形象是烟嘴、小胡子、矫揉造作。基本上就像是一个穿有人形睡衣的人。我觉得事实上，詹姆斯·邦德真正的灵感来源——对我来说
they're not real people and they're blindingly obvious they're two fictional characters one of them is Richard Hannay so that's John Buchan I mean you must have
它们不是真人，而是昭然若揭的两个虚构角色。其中一个就是理查德·汉内（Richard Hannay）——也就是约翰·巴肯（John Buchan）笔下的人物。你一定
read the 39 Steps I have and Green Mantle and Green Mantle exactly and all those brilliant books far better written
读过《三十九级台阶》（The 39 Steps）吧？我读过。还有《青寒》（Green Mantle）？《青寒》绝对读过，还有所有那些精彩绝伦的书，依我看，写得比伊恩·弗莱明的书好得多。
than the Ian Fleming books in my view and they also provide the inspiration for the Bond villain so Green Mantle has a kind of sinister figure in the background who's plotting a revolution and also has a female character what's her name Hilda von Einem I think her name is
而且它们还为邦德的反派提供了灵感。《青寒》中有一个潜伏在暗处、密谋发动革命的阴暗人物，里面还有一个女性角色——她叫什么名字来着？伊娜姆（Hilda von Einem），我想她在
in Green Mantle yes and there's also a super villain in a book called The Three Hostages called Dominic Medina. Yes. So he's a very Bond villain sort of character. So there's Richard Hannay. Richard Hannay is a South African...
《青寒》里叫这个名字，对吧？在一本名为《三名人质》（The Three Hostages）的书里还有一个超级反派，名叫多米尼克·梅迪纳（Dominic Medina）。是的。所以他是一个非常具有邦德反派色彩的角色。所以这就是理查德·汉内。理查德·汉内是一个南非人……
What is he? Has he been a mining engineer or something? He's a prospector, isn't he? Yeah, but he's an adventurer. Yeah. He's not a spy. he's a secret agent, which is true of Bond as well, because Bond does very little spying.
他是个什么人？他曾是个采矿工程师什么的吗？他是个勘探者，对吧？是的，但他是个冒险家。是的。他不是个间谍。他是个秘密特工，邦德也是如此，因为邦德其实没怎么干过间谍的活。
Also, that brilliant prescription in John McNabb, where there's, I think it's people in Clubland, like Ian Fleming was, who feel a bit kind of seedy, a bit drab, a bit like they may be a bit ill. And they go to the doctor and the doctor's prescription is that they should go and steal a horse from someone in a country
还有约翰·麦克纳布（John Macnab）里那个精彩的桥段：伊恩·弗莱明那样在俱乐部里厮混的人，觉得自己有点破落、有点乏味、感觉自己可能有点毛病。他们去看医生，医生的处方是让他们去某个盛行绞死偷马贼的国家，去偷走某人的马。
where horse thieves get hanged. That's brilliant. And it's that kind of idea idea that adventure for adventure's sake that's exactly hannay has that all the time hannay is always saying in the john buckham books he hates london he doesn't like peacetime he he dreams of life on the veldt you know when he could go big game hunting and stuff and the other and that's also a parallel with the other big inspiration i think for james bond which is bulldog drummond have you ever read bulldog drummond no i've never read by by a guy called hc mcneil sapper sapper was his nom de plume writing in the i imagine it's the kind of thing your brother
这太精彩了。正是这种为冒险而冒险的想法——汉内一直都是这样的。在约翰·巴肯的书里，汉内总是说他讨厌伦敦，他不喜欢和平时期，他梦想着维尔德（veldt）草原上的生活，你知道的，可以去进行猎奇探险之类的事情。而这，也与我认为詹姆斯·邦德的另一个巨大灵感来源不谋而合，那就是《牛头犬德拉蒙德》（Bulldog Drummond）。你读过《牛头犬德拉蒙德》吗？不，我从来没读过。作者是一个叫 H·C·麦克尼尔（H.C. McNeile）的人，笔名是“萨珀”（Sapper）。萨珀是他的笔名，写于——我猜这应该是你哥哥
and al murray would probably love um uh so he's writing the aftermath of the first world war and um bulldog drummond is a World War I veteran who's ugly. He's in a very sort of masculine, sexy way, not unlike Daniel Craig's Bond, I would say. And he drifts around Clubland as well. And basically he finds employment with his mates, fighting conspirators who are trying to undermine the British Empire and so on. So the villains in Bulldog Drummond,
和阿尔·默里（Al Murray）会非常喜欢的类型，嗯。所以他写的是第一次世界大战之后的事，嗯，牛头犬德拉蒙德是一名一战老兵，长得很丑。他是以一种非常具有雄性气质、性感的方式长得很丑，这一点其实跟丹尼尔·克雷格版的邦德挺像的，我觉得。他在俱乐部里游荡，基本上，他受雇于他的哥们儿，去和那些企图破坏大英帝国根基的阴谋家战斗，诸如此类。所以《牛头犬德拉蒙德》里的反派，
the main villain is a guy called Carl Peterson. And they're fantastic. They're a fantastic insight into the kind of paranoid imagination of the 1920s. So they're Germanic, they're Jewish, they're connected with Wall Street and high finance, but they're also funding Bolshevik left-wing... So they're rootless cosmopolitans.
最大的反派是一个叫卡尔·彼得森（Carl Peterson）的人。它们太棒了。它们让人极其深刻地洞察到 20 世纪 20 年代那种偏执狂的想象力。所以他们是日耳曼人、犹太人，与华尔街和金融高层有着千丝万缕的联系，但他们同时还在资助布尔什维克左翼分子……所以他们是无根的世界主义者。
They're absolute rootless cosmopolitans. And actually, that's true of fleming's villains as well so someone like blofeld blofeld is half polish half greek very kind of weird combination um and and he's drifted around europe before setting up specter which is itself pure rootless cosmopolitanism because specter um blowfeld's conspiratorial organization which is very 1920s actually has gestapo people in it and russians and yugoslavs and all kinds of dominic what about fu manchu the yes that must also be a part of the incredibly racist portrayal of a chinese supervillain yes because fu manchu is dr no um basically so Fu Manchu is created by Sax Roma
他们是彻头彻尾的无根的世界主义者。事实上，弗莱明书中的反派也是如此。比如像布洛费德（Blofeld），布洛费德是波兰和希腊的混血，非常奇特的组合，而且在建立“魔鬼党”（SPECTRE）之前一直在欧洲各地流荡。而“魔鬼党”本身就是纯粹的无根世界主义产物，因为“魔鬼党”——布洛费德的阴谋组织，其实非常具有 20 世纪 20 年代的特色——里面既有盖世太保成员，也有俄国人和南斯拉夫各种各样的人。多米尼克，那傅满洲（Fu Manchu）呢？是的，那一定也是对中国超级反派极其种族主义刻画的一部分吧？是的，因为傅满洲就是诺博士
starts in the 1910s so initially it's contempt Fu Manchu is the missing link I guess between Sherlock Holmes and James Bond so Fu Manchu starts between Professor Moriarty and Dr. No exact yes exactly so Fu Manchu starts in the 1910s uh it's pure kind of yellow peril kind of anti Chinese paranoia and then uh Sax Roma starts writing it again in the 1930s, and there are lots of Fu Manchu films. And this idea of the supervillain, whose agents are everywhere, who is un-British, who is physically repulsive, but is possessed of enormous mental powers,
的原型——基本上，傅满洲是由萨克斯·罗默（Sax Rohmer）创造的，
that's there in almost all the Fleming books. So almost all the Fleming books so almost all the Fleming James Bond villains are physically disgusting or deformed in some strange way that's right there's a very funny list in Simon Winder's book but they've got no lung or they're covered in hair or they have no hair or Blofeld has had his earlobes. He's got no earlobes. That's right. I mean, by that point, you know, they're getting a bit desperate.
始于 20 世纪 10 年代，所以最初它是蔑视性的。傅满洲大概是夏洛克·福尔摩斯和詹姆斯·邦德之间的“缺失环节”——所以傅满洲介于莫里亚蒂教授和诺博士之间，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以傅满洲诞生于 20 世纪 10 年代，带有纯粹的“黄祸论”式的反华偏执；然后萨克斯·罗默在 20 世纪 30 年代又开始续写，并且有很多傅满洲的电影。这种超级反派的概念——他的特工无处不在，非英国本土的，外表令人身体上感到排斥，但却拥有极其庞大的精神力量——
Yeah, Scaramanga has a third nipple. I mean, just ludicrous. Very peculiar. Well, again, I mean, you get an insight into... So Ian Fleming has this cocktail of stuff clearly floating around his head. Hané, Bulldog Drummond, Fu Manchu, all this stuff.
这一点在几乎所有的弗莱明小说中都有体现。所以几乎所有的弗莱明小说中——几乎所有的弗莱明詹姆斯·邦德反派在身体上都令人作呕，或者以某种奇怪的方式畸形。确实如此，西蒙·温德的书里有一个非常搞笑的清单，说他们没有肺，或者浑身是毛，或者没有头发，或者布洛费德切掉了耳垂。他没有耳垂。没错。我是说，到了那种地步，你知道的，他们已经有点走投无路了。
But he also has his own weird paranoias and neuroses. So he's in this weird relationship with his wife, Anne, the woman who becomes his wife, who was initially Lady Rothermere. And they have this strange, what appears to be a kind of sadomasochistic relationship. And there's tons of sadomasochism in the books. So who's the sadist and who's the masochist? It's very unclear.
对，斯卡拉曼加（Scaramanga）长了第三个乳头。我是说，简直荒谬至极。非常奇特。好吧，同样地，你可以从中窥见……所以伊恩·弗莱明的脑海里显然漂浮着这样一堆鸡尾酒式的杂烩。汉内、牛头犬德拉蒙德、傅满洲，所有这些东西。
I mean, in the books, either Bond says again and again to the sort of Bond girls, I will beat you, I will spank you, you know, I will hit you. And then there's an awful book called The Spy Who Loved Me, which is the only one narrated by a woman, by a woman, Vivienne Michel. How successful is that? Not very successful. And it's a really weird one,
但他也有着自己古怪的偏执与神经质。所以他和他妻子安妮（Anne）——也就是后来成为他妻子的那个女人，最初是罗瑟米尔爵士夫人（Lady Rothermere）——维持着一种诡异的关系。他们之间似乎存在着一种奇怪的、某种萨德式的（sadomasochistic）虐恋关系。小说里充斥着大量的虐恋情节。那么，谁是施虐者，谁又是受虐者呢？这其实很不清楚。
because I think I'm trying to, it's yonk since I read it and I tried to blank it out. I think she's staying at a motel and two men attack her and Bond is the stranger who intervenes to rescue her. So there's no sort of conspiracy or espionage or anything really in it um but she says it at various points in that book you know all women love to be taken they love to be treated roughly and and this fleming attempting to kind of ventriloquize what a woman thinks and it's obviously utterly disastrous
我是说，在书里，邦德一次又一次地对那些邦德女郎说：“我要揍你，我要打你屁股，你知道的，我要打你。”然后还有一本糟糕透顶的书叫《海底城》（The Spy Who Loved Me），这是唯一一本由女性叙述的小说，通过一个女性——薇薇安·米歇尔（Vivienne Michel）的视角来讲述。这本书有多成功？不太成功。而且这是一本非常诡异的书，
because it's just his fantasy of what a woman wants because um is it is it in dr no the novel that the villain ties the girl up and threatens her with being devoured by crabs um i think there is i think there is some stuff about crabs she's tied up naked to a rock and he kind of shivers with delight at the thought of all the crabs coming up and pinching. And clearly something's going on with the plumbing there. Something very strange is going on there. Is he whistling while he's doing it? That's the question.
因为我在努力——我已经好久没读过了，我一直在试图把它从脑海里抹去。我记得她住在一家汽车旅馆里，两个男人袭击了她，而邦德作为一个陌生人介入并拯救了她。所以里面其实并没有什么阴谋或者间谍活动之类的东西。但她在书中的不同地方说过这样的话：“所有的女人都喜欢被征服，她们喜欢被粗暴对待。”这是弗莱明试图以内心独白的方式去揣摩一个女性的想法，而这显然是一场彻底的灾难，
Yes. Well, I think that's a good question on which to perhaps go for a break, have a martini. We could do some brand product placement um all the kind of bond stuff uh and when we come back let's look at the way that um the novels develop and then migrate into the films okay and the the chasm of difference that has really opened up between between uh the mores of ian fleming and the. So we'll see you back in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde.
因为这不过是他对女性渴望什么的臆想。因为，嗯——是不是在小说《诺博士》里，反派把女孩绑起来，并威胁说要让螃蟹把她活活吃掉？我想是的，我想确实有些关于螃蟹的桥段。她赤身裸体地被绑在岩石上，而反派一想到无数的螃蟹爬过来夹她，就兴奋得浑身战栗。显然，他的脑回路出了一点问题。那里的水管出了非常奇怪的故障。他在干这事的时候还在吹口哨吗？这才是问题所在。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are talking James Bond. And Dominic, we've looked at Ian Fleming, we've looked at possible inspirations. Let's look at the novels now.
是的。好吧，我觉得这是一个很好的切入点，也许我们该去休息一下，喝杯马提尼。我们可以做点品牌植入广告，嗯，各种邦德元素……等我们回来，让我们来看看小说的发展轨迹，以及它们是如何搬上大银幕的，好吗？还有伊恩·弗莱明的风气与现代之间真正拉开的巨大鸿沟。我们一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And there's a great question here from Sam Zarifi. How would we view a Bond-like character from the other side? A Soviet or Chinese or Iranian agent granted a licence to kill and blow up institutions of Western power. Should Bond finally face justice for his actions? Must Bond fall? Yes. Well, obviously, Bond has killed a lot of people, so I suppose there are probably a lot of people out there
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在聊詹姆斯·邦德。多米尼克，我们讨论了伊恩·弗莱明，也讨论了可能的灵感来源。现在让我们来看看小说本身。
who would like to see Bond fall. How would it work? Well, I mean, were there? Were there kind of Soviet equivalents? Yes there were and they did yes I mean there were tons especially in the 1960s there were tons of Soviet equivalents and Eastern Bloc equivalents
这里有一个来自萨姆·扎里菲（Sam Zarifi）的极好的问题：我们该如何从另一方的视角来看待一个“邦德式”的角色？一个被授予杀人执照并炸毁西方权力的机构的苏军、中方或伊朗特工。邦德最终应该为他的所作所为面临正义的审判吗？邦德必须倒台吗？是的。好吧，显然，邦德杀过很多人，所以我猜大概会有很多人
and indeed you know Italian French and so on lots of people tried to do James Bond I think the Britishness is absolutely central to Bond's image and Bond's success so I don't think they would so so there have been such agents but they haven't worked as international commercial phenomena. Why do you think that is? Well this is a very big question I think it's because the Britishness for a lot of people and not all listeners to this podcast I think will agree
希望看到邦德倒台。那会怎么运作呢？好吧，我是说，曾经有过吗？有过苏联的对标人物吗？是的，确实有，他们也这么做了。我是说，有很多，特别是在 20 世纪 60 年代，有大量的苏联对标人物和东欧阵营的对标人物，
with this but I think for a lot of people britishness represents a kind of class a kind of quality um which is why so it's a kind there's a kind of consumerist element to it so it's in the same way that for example if you're a recently you know if you're a chinese or an indian billionaire you you go and get your suit made on savile row and you buy a rolls royce and you employ a brit Savile Row and you buy a Rolls Royce. And you employ a British butler. And you employ a British butler, precisely. You don't, you know, you don't get an Italian butler. But you do. You go and buy a vineyard in France.
当然还有，你知道的，意大利人、法国人等等，很多人都尝试过创作詹姆斯·邦德。但我认为，英国本土特色（Britishness）对于邦德的形象和邦德的成功是绝对核心的，所以我不认为他们能成功——所以虽然有过这样的特工，但他们并没有作为国际商业现象取得成功。你认为这是为什么？好吧，这是一个非常宏大的问题。我认为这是因为，对于许多人来说——并非本播客的所有听众都会同意这一点——但我认为对于很多人而言，英国特色代表了一种阶层，一种品质，
You do, but there are specific British things that are seen to represent. So there's a sort of sense of a gentleman, you know, and you buy your house in Mayfair and you send your children to a British public school, indeed the same public school, Eton, that James Bond went to. But he also went to Fetty's, didn't he? He did, because he was kicked out of Eton for some mischief with a maid.
正因如此，它带有一种消费主义的元素。所以它的运作方式就像这样：比方说，如果你是一个刚发迹的——如果你是一个中国或印度的亿万富豪，你会去萨维尔街（Savile Row）定制西装，买一辆劳斯莱斯，然后雇佣一个英国管家。劳斯莱斯，并雇佣一个英国管家。而且你确实会雇佣一个英国管家，没错。你不会，你知道的，你不会去雇佣一个意大利管家。但你会去法国买个葡萄园。
Which is Tony Blair's old school. Yeah, a very different man. Yeah, and Tilda Swinton. Tilda Swinton, interesting. She went there as well, apparently. Maybe she could play James Bond in some gender neutral or whatever
你确实会，但有些特定的英国事物被视为代表了某种标准。所以有一种绅士的观念，你知道的，你在梅费尔（Mayfair）买栋房子，把你的孩子送到英国公学去读寄宿学校——事实上，就是詹姆斯·邦德去过的那所公学，伊顿公学。但他还去过费蒂斯公学（Fettes），对吧？是的，因为他在伊顿惹了点女佣的麻烦而被开除了。
remake anyway yeah so I think that Britishness is really important and I think Bond could only work in a world
那是托尼·布莱尔（Tony Blair）的母校。是的，一个截然不同的人。是的，还有蒂尔达·斯文顿（Tilda Swinton）。蒂尔达·斯文顿，很有意思。她好像也是那里毕业的。也许她可以在某种性别中立或者其他什么风格的重拍片里扮演詹姆斯·邦德。
in which the British Empire had ceased to matter very like the Beatles very like the Beatles Tom they only succeed because Britishness is cool and not scary matter which is okay so that's very like the beatles very like the beatles tom okay only succeed because britishness is cool and not scary okay so there's a question from from stephanie empson yeah friend of the show yes how important has james bond been relative to the beatles in shaping global perceptions of post-imperial britain i think very important so that's the
总之，是的，所以我觉得这种英国特色真的很重要。而且我认为，邦德只能在一个大英帝国已经不再重要、不再具有威胁的世界里运作——这非常像披头士乐队（The Beatles）。非常像披头士乐队，汤姆，他们之所以能成功，仅仅是因为英国特色变得很酷，而不再让人感到可怕，这就对了——所以这非常像披头士乐队，非常像披头士乐队，汤姆，好吧，他们之所以能成功，仅仅是因为英国特色变得很酷，而不再让人感到可怕，好吧——这里有一个来自斯蒂芬妮·埃姆普森（Stephanie Empson）的问题——本节目的老朋友，是的——在塑造全球对“后帝国时代英国”的认知方面，詹姆斯·邦德相对于披头士乐队而言有多重要？我认为非常重要。所以这就是
films basically isn't it yeah purely the film films start to be released in the 60s. Yes, 1962. So the films start to be released at perfect timing, at precisely the point where Britain no longer is a sort of top, top-ranked player in world affairs. And it's when the Union Jack is becoming a kind of ironic symbol. Exactly. And Bond plays a big part in driving that.
电影的作用，对吧？是的，纯粹是电影。电影在 60 年代开始上映。是的，1962 年。所以电影开始上映的时机完美得不可思议，恰好是在英国不再是世界事务中顶尖玩家的那个时间点。正是在那个时候，米字旗开始变成了一种具有讽刺意味的符号。没错。而邦德在推动这一转变的过程中扮演了极其重要的角色。
It's very like the Beatles. So it's both a symptom and a cause. And I think Bond and the Beatles together are the two most important things in creating an image of Britain as modern, Britain as cool, as funny, as knowing, self-aware. All those things which were not part of our brand when our brand was dreadnoughts and making ball bearings.
这非常像披头士乐队。所以它既是一个症状，也是一个诱因。我认为邦德和披头士乐队结合在一起，是塑造英国形象最重要的两股力量：把英国塑造为一个现代的、酷的、有趣的、懂行的、有自我意识的国度。所有这些特质，在我们曾经的品牌是以无畏舰和制造滚珠轴承为代表的年代里，是根本不存在于我们的品牌形象之中的。
But after those things no longer matter, then we kind of reinvented our brand. And I think Bond was... I mean, Bond is... The Britishness of Bond is always ambiguous, isn't it? Because Bond takes pleasure in it. You know, what's Bond doing? Keeping the British end up, sir.
但当这些事情不再重要之后，我们便重塑了我们的品牌。而且我认为邦德是——我是说，邦德是……邦德身上的英国特色总是模棱两可的，不是吗？因为邦德从中找到了乐趣。你知道的，邦德在做什么？“保持英国的尊严，长官。”
And sort of, he's got a Union Jack parachute and all these kind of things. And yet at the time he's also it's sort of self-aware and he's poking fun at it and i think um that that only works in a country that has been powerful and now has lost a lot of that power um but has lost it in this sort of not in a terribly traumatic way that so it's it's it's perfectly happy to joke about it and to kind of ironise it. And I don't think there are many other countries that were in the same position to do that kind of thing. For example, France's loss of power, I think,
而且某种程度上，他带着米字旗的降落伞以及所有这些东西。然而与此同时，他又带有自我意识，并且在自我取笑。我认为，这种特质只有在一个曾经强大、如今失去了大部分权力的国家里才能行得通——但这种权力的丧失并不是以一种极具创伤性的方式发生的，所以它完全乐意去开玩笑、去将之戏剧化、自嘲一番。我想没有几个其他国家处于能够做到这一点的相同位置。例如，我认为法国失去权力的过程可能要痛苦得多，因为阿尔及利亚战争和纳粹占领等等。英国则完全没有这些。所以英国可以——英国文化可以对英国特色、维多利亚主义以及帝国开玩笑，而这是其他国家所做不到的。不过，关于这个资源，我要在这里引用一位该领域的顶尖专家的言论。
was probably much more traumatic because of Algeria and the occupation and so on. Britain has none of that. So Britain can kind of, British culture can kind of make a joke about Britishness and about Victorianism and the empire in a way that other countries don't. But the resource, I'm going to quote here a leading specialist on the subject.
是的。与披头士乐队的不同之处在于——这位顶尖专家写道——邦德，按照我们的理解，是那种经常玩百家乐（baccarat）的人，而不是那种把整个晚上消磨在巴恩斯利（Barnsley）工人俱乐部的男人。是的，那是我写的。
Yeah. The difference with the Beatles, and the leading specialist writes this, Bond, we are led to understand, is the kind of man who plays a lot of baccarat, not the kind of man who spends his evenings at working men's clubs in Barnsley. Yeah, that's me.
从弗莱明第一本小说的开篇句子，到《天幕杀机》（Skyfall）的最后一个场景，世上从未有过比这更具诱惑力的上流社会建制广告了。是的，千真万确。那是你写的。对，当然是你写的，因为那是你写的作品。好吧，我坚持我自己的观点。
From the opening sentences of Fleming's first book, The Last Scene of Skyfall, there has never been a more seductive advertisement for the upper-class establishment. Yeah, that's true. That was you. Yeah, of course you do, because you write it. Well, I stand by my own words.
不，我认为邦德提供了一种愿景，一种关于上流社会英国特色的、极其一成不变的愿景。你看，这正是我所错过的，因为我只见过穿着萨法里猎装（safari suit）的罗杰·摩尔。是的，那大概是这种特质最不明显的时候。但即使是现在，丹尼尔·克雷格——我是说，丹尼尔·克雷格来自威勒尔（Wirral）。他是一个酒吧老板的儿子。
No, I think Bond is offering a vision, a remarkably unchanging vision of upper-class Britishness. You see, that's what I missed, because I had Roger Moore in a safari suit. Yeah, and that's probably the point at which that was least pronounced. But even now, Daniel Craig. I mean, Daniel Craig is from the Wirral. He's the son of a pub landlord.
或者皮尔斯·布鲁斯南（Pierce Brosnan）。皮尔斯·布鲁斯南是一个爱尔兰移民，曾在综合中学读书。所以扮演角色的演员与角色本身之间总是存在着一丝张力。肖恩·康纳利（Sean Connery）绝对也是如此。而且肖恩·康纳利也确实如此，他曾当过送奶工和健美运动员。来自 Capital Loft 的有一个极好的问题：书中的邦德是个苏格兰人，他曾被苏格兰人、澳大利亚人、两个英国人、一个威尔士人和一个爱尔兰人所扮演，但许多人却将他视为英国特色的化身。这向我们揭示了关于不断变化的……
Or Pierce Brosnan. Pierce Brosnan, an Irish immigrant who went to a comprehensive school. So there's always a slight tension between the person playing the part and the character. And that was definitely true of Sean Connery. And that's true of Sean Connery, milkman and bodybuilder. There's a great question from Capital Loft. Bond in the books is a Scot who's been played by a Scot, an Australian, two Englishmen, a Welshman and an Irishman, but is seen as the epitome of englishness by many what does he tell us about the changing
或者是皮尔斯·布鲁斯南。皮尔斯·布鲁斯南是一位爱尔兰移民，曾在一所综合学校就读。所以扮演角色的演员和角色本身之间总是存在着一丝微妙的张力。肖恩·康纳利绝对也是如此。肖恩·康纳利曾是一名送奶工和健美运动员，情况确实如此。Capital Loft 提了一个非常棒的问题：书中的邦德是一个苏格兰人，这个角色曾由苏格兰人、澳大利亚人、两个英国人、一个威尔士人和一个爱尔兰人扮演，但许多人却将他视为英国特质的化身，这向我们揭示了关于这种不断变化的...
beliefs and anxieties about britain post world war ii well i think i saw that question i thought what a great question it was because it's very hard to answer unambiguously because there is a kind of ambiguity about bond the bond character is half scott, half Swiss. So his father was a Scottish, supposedly, worked for a Scotsman who worked for an arms manufacturer, Vickers, and his wife, Monique, came from Switzerland and they die in a climbing accident. Bond is initially educated abroad, and then he goes to Eton. And in fact, I'll just read you out something from Moonraker, one of the early Bond books. Bond is reflecting on his own appearance, and he says of himself, something a bit cold and dangerous in that face.
关于二战后英国的信仰与焦虑，我想我看到那个问题时，觉得它真是个好问题，因为很难给出明确的回答，因为邦德身上有一种模棱两可的特质，邦德这个角色一半是苏格兰人，一半是瑞士人。所以据说他的父亲是个苏格兰人，为一家军火制造商维克斯公司的苏格兰雇员工作，他的妻子莫尼克来自瑞士，他们在一次登山事故中双双身亡。邦德最初在国外受教育，后来去了伊顿公学。事实上，我给你们读一段早期邦德小说《太空城》里的内容。邦德在反思自己的外表时，他这样评价自己：那张脸上有种冷酷而危险的东西。
Looks pretty fit. May have been attached to Templar in Malaya or Nairobi. Mau Mau work. Tough-looking customer. Bond knew there was something alien and un-English about himself. He knew he was a difficult man to cover up, particularly in England. He shrugged his shoulders. Abroad was what mattered. He would never to cover up, particularly in England. He shrugged his shoulders. Abroad was what mattered.
看起来很健壮。可能曾在马来亚或内罗毕的圣殿骑士团待过。处理过茅茅起义。是个强悍的家伙。邦德知道自己身上有一种格格不入、不像英国人的特质。他知道自己很难掩饰，尤其是在英国。他耸了耸肩膀。国外才是重要的。他绝不会掩饰，尤其是在英国。他耸了耸肩膀。国外才是重要的。
He would never have a job to do in England. Of course, the irony is in Moonraker, it's set entirely in England, in the book. But he's un-English. And his un-Englishness, I think, is... He's like Hannay to that extent. So he's kind of... It's as though contemporary England has become dissipated and unmanned, and Bond is a sort of flashback to an
他永远不会在英国有工作要做。当然，讽刺的是，《太空城》这本书完全以英国为背景。但他不是英国人。而他的非英国特质，我认为是……从这一点上来说他就像汉尼。所以他有点……就好像当代的英国已经变得消沉、失去锐气，而邦德就像是对一个
old a vanished age and the reason that he can be that is because of his un-Englishness so in a weird way having un-English people play him kind of makes sense but you're right that abroad this is the really weird and strange thing that abroad people see him as the consummate englishman and a lot of that i think is to do with the suit the style the swagger and the sense of of of complete knowledge and confidence so bond can walk into any hotel anywhere in the world ah mr bond your usual suite which is not good stuff for spy is it no but he's not a spy he's not a spy that's the point about james bob everyone thinks he's not well he doesn't do any spying he's basically he just walks around drinking expensive drinks and buying consumer durables well exactly he's a consumerist fantasy
古老、消逝的时代的某种闪回，他之所以能成为这样的人，正是因为他不具备英国人的特质。所以从某种诡异的角度来看，让不具英国血统的人来演他倒也说得通；但你说得对，在国外，这真是极其诡异而奇怪的事情，国外的人把他视为完美的英国绅士，而我觉得这很大程度上与他的西装、风格、气场以及那种全知全能的自信有关。所以邦德可以走进世界上任何一家酒店：“啊，詹姆斯·邦德先生，您惯常的套房。”这可不是间谍该有的待遇，对吧？不，但他不是间谍，他不是间谍，这就是詹姆斯·邦德的关键所在，大家都觉得他不是——好吧，他根本不做任何间谍工作，他基本上就是四处闲逛，喝着昂贵的饮料，购买耐用消费品。完全没错，他就是一个消费主义的幻想。
agrees but he's always he's basically an assassin that's i think what james bond is if you're an assassin i mean if that an assassin. That's, I think, what James Bond is. Yeah, but even so, if you're an assassin, I mean, if that's your job and everyone knows who you are... I mean, I'm aware it's not a realist novel. Yeah, but it's terrifying, though. You're scared because you know James Bond is coming. He's just checked into the presidential suite in the city's leading five-star hotel.
完全同意，但他一直以来……他基本上是个刺客，我想詹姆斯·邦德就是这样的人，如果你是一个刺客——我是说如果那是刺客的话。我想詹姆斯·邦德就是这样的人。是的，即便如此，如果你是一个刺客——我是说，如果那是你的工作，而且人尽皆知……我知道这不是一部现实主义小说。是的，但这也太吓人了。你会感到害怕，因为你知道詹姆斯·邦德要来了。他刚刚登记入住该市顶级的五星级酒店的总统套房。
He's eating oysters and ordering martinis. He's smoking very high, specially prepared high nicotine cigarettes, of which apparently he smokes 70 a day. I mean, the thing about Bond, my son said this to me the other day, we were talking about James Bond, and he said, does every major luxury hotel in the world have a suite prepared for James Bond on the off chance? You know, whenever he walks in, I never check into a hotel like that.
他正在吃生蚝，点马提尼。他在抽一种非常高级的、特制的尼古丁含量很高的香烟，据说他一天要抽70支。我的意思是，关于邦德，我儿子前几天跟我说过这个，我们在聊詹姆斯·邦德，他说：“难道世界上每家豪华酒店都为詹姆斯·邦德准备了一间套房，以防万一吗？”你知道的，每当他走进去的时候——我从来没有这样入住过酒店。
People say, oh, the room's not ready. Actually, we don't have a suite hanging around. This guy walks in with emphysema, puffing and wheezing. Oh, Mr. Bond. They're never fully booked. No. Well, goodness.
人们会说：“哦，房间还没准备好。事实上，我们没有空闲的套房。”这家伙走进来时肺气肿发作，呼哧带喘的。“哦，邦德先生。”他们从来都不是客满的。没有。真是的。
But having said that, and you mentioned Moonraker, which I was intrigued, because Moonraker of course i know as as the attempt to rip off star wars i'm kind of yeah one of my favorite fakedly corpulent roger moore doing an improbable impression of leet skywalker yeah which was i mean you could perhaps say summed up late 70s Britain. There's a fantastic, one of my favourite Bond moments, actually,
话虽如此，你提到了《太空城》，这让我很感兴趣，因为《太空城》在我看来是对《星球大战》的拙劣模仿，我有点……是的，这是我最喜欢的装腔作势、身材臃肿的罗杰·摩尔对莱特·天行者的一次不可能的模仿，这可以算作是对70年代末英国的总结。这是一个非常精彩的片段，其实也是我最喜欢的邦德时刻之一，
is when he walks into sort of Nassau or whatever, and he's looking for, he's been told to look for Dr. Goodhead. Dr. Goodhead. He says, I'm looking for Dr. Goodhead. And there's a woman there standing with a clipboard. She says, you just found her. And he says, a woman? Kind of such disbelief. And Mortief for his eyebrows halfway up his head with amazement that a woman could have a doctorate and be called good head oh yes dr holly good head
就是当他走进拿骚还是什么地方，他正在寻找——他被告知去寻找古德黑德博士。古德黑德博士。他说：“我在找古德黑德博士。”那里站着一个拿着写字板的女人。她说：“你刚找到她。”他说：“一个女人？”带着那种难以置信的语气。莫蒂夫惊讶得眉毛都挑到额头一半高了，不敢相信一个女人居然能拥有博士学位，名字还叫“古德黑德”——哦，是的，霍莉·古德黑德博士。
yeah dear oh dear but the original moon wrecker i was intrigued to read is is you mentioned this is set entirely in england it is and revolves around around Sir Hugo Drax, who is a model clubman, who then turns out to have been a Nazi. But he cheats, doesn't he? That's the giveaway. He's been cheating at cards. And also he sucked his thumb at public school. M says he cheated at cards.
是的，天哪天哪。但原著《太空城》，我很好奇地读到——你提到过这个，故事完全发生在英国，它围绕着雨果·德拉克斯爵士展开，他是一个模范俱乐部屋主，后来却被发现是个纳粹分子。但他作弊了，不是吗？这就是破绽。他在打牌时作弊。而且他在公立学校时还吸吮拇指。M说他在打牌时作弊。
So that shows there's something a bit off about him. You know, check him out. Bond checks him out and discovers that Sir Hugo is actually... Is he Graf Hugo von der Drache? Is he a German war criminal or something? And he's going to fire these missiles back at Britain and destroy Britain. Nuclear missiles. In revenge for having been bullied at public school.
这表明他有点不对劲。你知道的，去查查他。邦德查了他，发现雨果爵士实际上是……他是雨果·冯·德·德拉切伯爵吗？他是个德国战犯什么的？他打算把这些导弹发射回英国，摧毁英国。核导弹。为了报复他在公立学校遭受的霸凌。
For sucking his son. Yeah. There's a lot going on there. There's an awful... Yeah, there's an awful... And also, Sir Hugo Drax was named after Admiral Sir Reginald Aylmer Ranferley Plunkett Earnley Early Drax.
因为吸吮拇指。是的。那里有很多内幕。有太多的……是的，有太多的……而且，雨果·德拉克斯爵士的名字是以海军上将雷金纳德·艾尔默·兰费利·普伦凯特·厄恩利·厄利·德拉克斯爵士的名字命名的。
Well, everybody's named after somebody. Yes, so Blofeld is named after the father of Henry Blofeld, the plummy-voiced cricket commentator. Exactly. Exactly. I thought you'd enjoy that. Well, I was going to.
好吧，每个人的名字都是随某人取的。是的，所以布洛费德的名字取自亨利·布洛费德的父亲，那个声音甜美的板球评论员。正是如此。正是如此。我想你会喜欢这个的。嗯，我本来打算的。
I was going to open with that, actually. But then I got your... This thing about whistling. Whistling. Well, Goldfinger. Goldfinger is an architect. And he was a modernist architect. And Erno Goldfinger.
我本来打算以此开场的，其实。但后来我收到了你的……关于吹口哨的这个。吹口哨。好吧，金手指。金手指是个建筑师。他是个现代主义建筑师。埃尔诺·金手指。
And Fleming had a violent... Because Fleming was so reactionary, he disliked everything about the modern world and modern Britain, and he hated Goldfinger's modern architecture. And so he initially... He named the character Goldfinger. Erno Goldfinger was outraged and threatened to sue him. And Fleming said if he was forced to change it,
弗莱明对此有着强烈的……因为弗莱明非常反动，他讨厌现代世界和现代英国的一切，他讨厌金手指的现代建筑。所以他最初……他给这个角色取名叫金手指。埃尔诺·金手指对此大发雷霆，并威胁要起诉他。弗莱明说，如果他被迫更改，
he would change it to gold prick instead. And Erno Goldfinger decided that, you know, to withdraw from the fray at that point, that he would just have to lump it. But it must be incredibly frustrating for Erno Goldfinger. He was a very acclaimed modernist architect. Yes. Basically, you know, his name is now famous for Oddjob
他就会把名字改成“金阴茎”。埃尔诺·金手指最终决定，在这个时候退出这场争端，他只能自认倒霉。但对于埃尔诺·金手指来说，这一定极其令人沮丧。他是一位备受赞誉的现代主义建筑师。是的。基本上，你知道的，他的名字现在因为“奇手”
throwing his bowler hat that kills people. Yes. You don't know what I'm talking about, do you? No, I do. Because, again, I've read your book. OK. Oddjob has no feeling in his hands, and so he can do karate jobs. Yes.
扔礼帽杀人而闻名。是的。你不知道我在说什么，对吧？不，我知道。因为，同样地，我读过你的书。好的。奇手的手没有知觉，所以他可以施展空手道重击。是的。
He's a very impressive person, Oddjob. I mean, if I was going to employ a personal gentleman... A manservant to kill people. That's what you'd do. He's go for absolutely okay well so so all this i mean it's all very odd um and as i said i think it's much older than say sherlock holmes which kind of focuses attention on the scale of change that's happened over the past decade so there's a question from james beamish is james bond one of the best windows into the change of the concept of masculinity over time from the faint misogyny of connery to the suave and funny more and now with craig whose character
奇手是个非常令人印象深刻的人。我的意思是，如果我要雇佣一个私人绅士……一个杀人的男仆。这就是你会做的事。他会全力以赴——好吧，所以这一切——我的意思是，这一切都非常古怪，而且正如我所说，我认为它比福尔摩斯之类的要古老得多，这把人们的注意力吸引到了过去十年所发生变化的规模上。所以这里有一个来自詹姆斯·比米什的问题：詹姆斯·邦德是否是洞察不同时期男性气质概念变迁的最佳窗口之一？从康纳利微弱的厌女症，到温文尔雅又滑稽的摩尔，再到如今克雷格的角色
is somewhat conflicted and flawed well i think that's a brilliant question it is a brilliant question i'm quite right but i would say that the the character being somewhat conflicted and flawed you know craig daniel craigs is because you're having to reconcile james bond created by this awful man in fleming with the radically different assumptions of society now aren't you absolutely yes and i think the only way they the only way they can do that without dropping much of what makes James Bond James Bond is to make his masculinity kind of toxic, to use the current jargon. So, you know, whereas in the 1960s, Sean Connery drank a lot, you know, slapped women on the backside. He was ostentatiously kind of misogynistic and audiences thought it was hilarious and liberated or at least male audiences did you couldn't do that now and so all when daniel craig he's seen as drinking too much his womanizing is seen as a sign of his failure to
多少有些矛盾和有瑕疵？我觉得这是一个极其精彩的问题。这确实是个极其精彩的问题，完全正确，但我要说的是，这个角色之所以显得有些矛盾和有瑕疵——你知道的，丹尼尔·克雷格版的邦德之所以如此，是因为你必须将这个由弗莱明这个糟糕的家伙创造的詹姆斯·邦德，与当今社会截然不同的观念调和起来，难道不是吗？完全是，是的。我认为他们唯一能做到这一点，又不会抛弃太多让詹姆斯·邦德成为詹姆斯·邦德的特质的方法，就是让他的男子气概带有一种“有毒”的色彩，用当下的流行语来说。所以，你知道的，在20世纪60年代，肖恩·康纳利酗酒，你知道的，拍打女人的屁股。他有着招摇的厌女症，观众觉得这滑稽又解放，或者至少男观众觉得如此。现在你可不能这么做了，所以当丹尼尔·克雷格扮演时，他被视为喝得太多，他的风流韵事被看作是他无法
form attachments um he's and he's portrayed as damaged in a way that James Bond in the 1960s never was. So there's something wrong with Daniel Craig's Bond. I wasn't so hinted in one of them that he had had gay experiences. Yes, right. So Javier Bardem's character, Raoul Silva, does a strange thing of stroking Daniel Craig's knees or something, and says, you know, I bet this is the first time for everything or something. And Daniel Craig
建立稳定关系的一种表现，呃，他被描绘成受过创伤的，这在20世纪60年代的詹姆斯·邦德身上是从来没有过的。所以丹尼尔·克雷格版的邦德身上有些毛病。其中一部电影不是暗示过他有过同性恋经历吗？是的，没错。所以哈维尔·巴登饰演的角色劳尔·席尔瓦，做了一个奇怪的举动，抚摸丹尼尔·克雷格的膝盖什么的，然后说，你知道的，我敢说这是破天荒第一次之类的话。丹尼尔·克雷格
says, what makes you think this is my first time? So have we ever heard Daniel Craig's Bond whistle? Well, Timothy Dalton's Bond whistles in a very interesting way, very, very, very timely, given the headlines at the moment. So he's imprisoned in Afghanistan in a Soviet airbase with a leader of Mujahideen. And the way he gets out is by whistling at his key fob, which is his gadget. He wolf whistles at this thing and it explodes, and he's able to escape from the cells with the Mujahideen leader,
说：“你怎么认为这是我的第一次？”那么我们听过丹尼尔·克雷格版的邦德吹口哨吗？好吧，蒂莫西·道尔顿版的邦德吹口哨的方式非常有趣，而且非常非常切合时事，考虑到当下的头条新闻。当时他被关在阿富汗的一个苏联空军基地里，和一个圣战者组织的领袖在一起。他逃脱的方式是对着他的车钥匙扣吹口哨，那个钥匙扣就是他的小玩意。他对这个东西发出了狼哨般的口哨声，然后它就爆炸了，他得以和圣战者组织的领袖一起从牢房里逃出来，
who it turns out went to Oxford Oh that's alright. So it's fine yeah so he would never have joined the Taliban. Is that Imran Khan? It's a character who's clearly, he's called Cameron Shah and he's played by Art Malik He's very very sophisticated he's very civilised
后来发现这个人还上过牛津大学。哦，那挺好。所以没问题，是的，所以他绝不会加入塔利班。那是伊姆兰·汗吗？这是一个特征非常明显的人物，他叫卡梅伦·沙阿，由阿特·马利克饰演。他非常非常老练，也非常文明，
I guess and very well with Bond So he's not a villain? The Mujahideen are tremendous fellows in the living daylights Okay, well here's another question perhaps for a James Bond episode the appropriately named Titmouse Right In brackets, maybe don't use his name
我猜，而且和邦德相处得很好。所以他不是个恶棍？在《黎明生机》里，圣战者们都是了不起的家伙。好吧，这里还有另一个问题，也许适合一期詹姆斯·邦德节目，提问者是名字非常恰当的“山雀”——对，括号里写着，也许别用他的名字。
Yeah, too late Yeah, too late Does Bond have to be white British male in order to remain true to the roots of the character? As with many people, I'd like to see Idris Elba do it. Well, Idris Elba is now much too old. But Dan Gray's quite old, isn't he? Yes, but they're not going to replace him
是的，太迟了。是的，太迟了。邦德必须是白人英国男性，才能忠于这个角色的根基吗？和许多人一样，我也想看到伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴来演。好吧，伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴现在年纪太大了。但丹·格雷年纪也挺大，不是吗？是的，但他们不会用
with somebody the same age or thereabouts. I suppose that's true. So does he have to be male? I think almost certainly yes. I mean, you could have a female secret agent. Of course you could. And you could do a whole series of films about a female secret agent. But it wouldn't be Bond.
一个同龄或差不多年纪的人来取代他。我想也是。那么他必须是男性吗？我认为几乎可以肯定是。我的意思是，你可以有一个女秘密特工。你当然可以。你可以拍一整部关于女秘密特工的系列电影。但那不会是邦德。
It wouldn't be Bond. The masculinity, the sort of what we would now call the toxic masculinity, is so central to Bond. I mean, that's one reason I think he's appealed. And he appeals in America. It's because he represents a vision of what it is to be a man. And obviously that's not going to work if Tilda Swinton plays him. Does he have to be British?
那不会是邦德。这种男子气概，也就是我们现在所说的有毒的男子气概，对邦德来说是如此核心。我的意思是，这也是我认为他受欢迎的原因之一。他在美国也很受欢迎。因为他代表了一种对男子汉应该是什么样子的愿景。很显然，如果由蒂尔达·斯文顿来扮演他，那就行不通了。他必须是英国人吗？
I think he has to be playing a character who works for the British Secret Service. I mean, at various points, the filmmakers have flirted with the idea of kind of Burt Reynolds or various American actors, but they've never done it. I think he has to be British or can pass for British. So he could be Southern. And Jason Bourne is a kind of an American attempt to have a...
我认为他必须扮演一个为英国秘密情报机构效力的角色。我的意思是，在不同的阶段，电影制片人曾试探过伯特·雷诺兹或各种美国演员的想法，但他们从未付诸实践。我认为他必须是英国人，或者能扮成英国人。所以他可以是南方人。而杰森·伯恩是美国人试图塑造的一个……
But nobody dreams of being Jason Bourne, do they? No. And you don't say to somebody, oh, that's the kind of thing Jason Bourne would do. You know, you don't order a drink that Jason Bourne... Bond is not just a character. He's a sort of collection of... Well, he's a collection of consumerist aspirants.
但没有人梦想成为杰森·伯恩，对吧？没有。而且你不会对某人说，“哦，那就是杰森·伯恩会做的事。”你知道的，你不会点一杯杰森·伯恩会点的饮料……邦德不仅仅是一个角色。他是一种集合……好吧，他是一群消费主义渴望者的集合。
He's a collection of brand names, isn't he? But as you say, British. Rooted in British style and class and snobbery, perhaps. Absolutely. Rooted in British snobbery. Now, the whiteness is the other interesting question. At what point could you have... I mean, clearly, a black bond in in 1980 there would have been probably a lot of consumer resistance uh audience resistance should we say
他是一系列品牌的集合，不是吗？但正如你所说，他是英国的。扎根于英国的风格、阶级，也许还有势利。绝对的。扎根于英国的势利。现在，白人身份是另一个有趣的问题。在什么阶段你可以拥有——我的意思是，很明显，在1980年一个黑人邦德可能会遭到很多消费者的抵制，呃，观众的抵制，我们可以这么说。
would there be audience resistance now i think it's unlikely actually i think you could quite comfortably have a um a black james bond what do you think i yeah i wouldn, I don't care. I mean, the interesting thing, well, great. I mean, whatever. The interesting thing is, I think you, I think the British, I think I would say a British audience would definitely wear a black James Bond.
现在还会有观众抵制吗？我觉得不太可能，事实上，我觉得你可以非常舒心地拥有一个黑人詹姆斯·邦德。你觉得呢？我——我不在乎。我的意思是，有趣的是，太棒了。我的意思是，无所谓。有趣的是，我认为你——我认为英国人，我想我会说英国观众绝对能接受一个黑人詹姆斯·邦德。
It'd be interesting whether, let's say, I mean, from the filmmaker's point of view, the two biggest audiences are probably the United States and China. Would they take a black British Bond I mean, what I'd say about Idris Elba and why people always seem to mention him is that he's very cool.
有趣的是，比方说，从电影制片人的角度来看，最大的两个观众群体可能是美国和中国。他们会接受一个黑人英国邦德吗？我的意思是，关于伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴，为什么人们总是提到他，我想说的是他非常酷。
Yes, and Bond is meant to be cool. And Sean Connery was clearly cool. And he was a Scottish noteworthy, wasn't he? And Ian Fleming was always complaining about it. Yeah. But because he was cool, he became basically the kind of the face of Bond. And he was much cooler than David Niven. Much cooler.
是的，邦德就是为了酷而设计的。肖恩·康纳利显然很酷。而且他是个值得注意的苏格兰人，对吧？伊恩·弗莱明总是对此抱怨连天。是的。但因为他很酷，他基本上成为了邦德的面孔。而且他比大卫·尼文酷得多。酷得多。
And Daniel Cage is quite cool, but Idris Elba is kind of off the scale cool. So in that sense, it would be returning to the model of Sean Connery, I guess. Yes. I think that's, I just think he's too old.
丹尼尔·克雷格挺酷，但伊德瑞斯·艾尔巴是那种超乎想象的酷。从这个意义上说，这将回归肖恩·康纳利的模式，我猜。是的。我认为——我只是觉得他太老了。
I accept that. But if he'd been cast, I don't know, 10 or 15 years ago. After The Wire or something. Yeah. Then I think he could yeah then i think he could have i think it absolutely could have done it yes i agree right um dominic do you think is
我接受这一点。但如果他在10年或15年前被选中演这个角色……在《火线重案组》之后之类的。是的。那我觉得他完全可以——那我觉得他本可以，我觉得他绝对能做到，是的，我同意。好的，呃，多米尼克，你觉得
there anything else you've got to say about bond as a cultural phenomenon shedding light on recent history or can we get on to the question from sam mb who is the best Bond and Diego Morgado which Bond film is the best you got anything I've got loads to say but clearly you're desperate, you're dying to get onto these questions so let's get onto these questions so who's the best Bond who's the best Bond, well
关于邦德作为一个文化现象对阐明近期历史的意义，你还有什么要说的吗？还是我们可以回答山姆·MB的问题：谁是最好的邦德？以及迭戈·莫尔加多的问题：哪部邦德电影最好？你有什么要说的吗？我有好多话要说，但很显然你急不可耐，渴望回答这些问题，那我们就来回答这些问题吧。谁是最好的邦德？谁是最好的邦德？好吧。
see my favourite Bond is not the best Bond, my favourite Bond is obviously Roger Moore because he's the Bond I grew up with and I like his ironic take on the character. And I find that tragically, I actually still find it very funny. There's also a very, very
看，我最喜欢的邦德并不是最好的邦德，我最喜欢的邦德显然是罗杰·摩尔，因为他是伴随我成长的邦德，我喜欢他对这个角色的讽刺性演绎。而且我悲哀地发现，我其实依然觉得非常搞笑。还有一个非常非常
good story about Roger Moore that paints him in an absolutely splendid light. Have you seen this circulating on Twitter? I have, but tell it because a lot of people may not have heard it. There's a bloke who um ended up working in tv and film and he tells a story about how when he was a little boy he went on he was traveling i think at nice airport with his grandfather in the days when airport passengers were not really
棒的故事讲的是罗杰·摩尔，这展现了他极其光辉的一面。你在推特上看到过这个传闻吗？我看过，但你讲讲吧，因为很多人可能没听过。有个家伙，呃，后来在电视和电影界工作，他讲了一个故事，说当他还是个小男孩的时候，他去过——我想是在尼斯机场，和他的祖父一起，在那个机场旅客还不像现在这样按阶级或其他标准严格隔离的年代，
segregated by class or whatever and he sees roger moore this is when roger moore is playing james bond and he goes up and he asks Roger Moore for his autograph. And Roger Moore, or his grandfather, gets the autograph for him. And it comes back and the autograph is there, Roger Moore. And this little boy who's seven is devastated because he hasn't signed it as James Bond. He's signed it as this man that he's never heard of. So the grandfather goes back or something and says,
他看到了罗杰·摩尔，当时罗杰·摩尔正在扮演詹姆斯·邦德，他走过去向罗杰·摩尔索要签名。然后罗杰·摩尔——或者他的祖父帮他拿到了签名。拿回来一看，上面签的是“罗杰·摩尔”。这个七岁的小男孩心碎了，因为他签的不是“詹姆斯·邦德”。他签的是这个他从未听说过的男人的名字。于是祖父又走回去或者怎么样，说：
why haven't you signed it as James Bond? He says, well, I've done it under an assumed name because I'm worried that Blofeld is here. Blofeld, we're listening. It's a lovely thing to have done. And many, many years later, this boy has grown up and he's working as a lighting man or a cameraman or something for a film they're doing for UNICEF.
“你为什么不签詹姆斯·邦德的名字？”他说：“哦，我用了一个化名，因为我担心布洛费德在这里。”“布洛费德，我们在听着呢。”这是一个非常可爱的举动。很多很多年以后，这个男孩长大了，他作为灯光师或摄像师之类的员工，参与制作一部为联合国儿童基金会拍摄的电影。
And Roger Moore, who did a lot for unicef is doing it and um at some point this bloke says to roger moore you you know you won't remember this but when i was seven you did a lovely thing where you signed an autograph for me and then you said you had to sign it as roger moore not as bond because uh blowfaults was listening and um roger moore said oh you're right i don't remember it but that sounds lovely thank you for telling me and all this kind of thing they do the days filming and at the end roger moore's on his way out roger moore stops by this bloke and he whispers to him he says of course i remembered it but of course i remembered it but i couldn't admit it because any of these any of
而为联合国儿童基金会做了很多贡献的罗杰·摩尔正在参与其中，呃，在某个时候，这家伙对罗杰·摩尔说：“你——你知道的，你可能不记得了，但我七岁的时候，你做了一件很可爱的事，你给我签了名，然后你说你必须签罗杰·摩尔的名字，而不是邦德的名字，因为呃，布洛费德在偷听。”呃，罗杰·摩尔说：“哦，你说得对，我不记得了，但这听起来真可爱，谢谢你告诉我这些，诸如此类的话。”他们完成了当天的拍摄，在离开的时候，罗杰·摩尔在这个家伙身边停了下来，低声对他说：“我当然记得，
these other crewmen could be working for blow felt and And he kind of goes off. It's such a lovely thing for him to have done. I know, I know, I know. So for that reason... He's the favourite Bond, but not the best, perhaps. No, I think the best in terms of the... Well, obviously the canonical Bond is Connery. Connery created the character. Without Connery...
我当然记得，但我不能承认，因为这里的任何其他剧组人员都可能是布洛费德派来的。”然后他就走开了。他做这事真是太可爱了。我知道，我知道，我知道……所以出于这个原因……他是最喜欢的邦德，但也许不是最好的？不，我认为就……好吧，显然正统的邦德是康纳利。康纳利塑造了这个角色。没有康纳利……
I mean, Connery only did it because he was cheap. So the first Bond film, Doctor No, the budget was a million dollars, which is nothing in early 1960s Hollywood. They got Connery because it's cheap, because it's tied to a franchise that probably isn't going to do very well. And Connery completely makes it. And had they employed almost anybody else,
我的意思是，康纳利接演只是因为他便宜。所以第一部邦德电影《诺博士》，预算是一百万美元，这在20世纪60年代初的好莱坞简直微不足道。他们选了康纳利是因为他便宜，因为这部电影绑定在一个可能不会卖座的系列上。而康纳利完全撑起了这部电影。如果他们雇用了几乎任何其他人，
I don't think it would have been successful. So Connery is the sort of founding father, really, arguably just as much as Ian Fleming. In terms of the best actor, I mean, there's no question, Daniel Craig is by far the best actor and he's given by far the most kind of multi... I mean, insofar as James Bond is multi-layered.
我认为它都不会成功。所以康纳利可以说是当之无愧的奠基之父，可以说和伊恩·弗莱明不相上下。就最好的演员而言，毫无疑问，丹尼尔·克雷格是迄今为止最好的演员，他贡献了迄今为止最丰富——我的意思是，就詹姆斯·邦德具有多重维度而言。
But is that what people want, necessarily? Well, he's been tremendously successful, Daniel Craig's Bond. I mean, coming at a point where... So the previous Bond film, Die Another Day, before Craig took over, had been an absolute joke with the kind of invisible car and Madonna was in it and it was just rubbish it was awful Pierce Brosnan's last film and Craig really turned it around so he'll be very hard to replace I think but he's taken it as far as you can in kind of a very hard sort of hard-edged Conflicted bond. I mean they'll have to go back to a slightly more Roger Powers
但这一定是人们想要的吗？好吧，丹尼尔·克雷格版的邦德获得了巨大的成功。我的意思是，在这样一个节点出现……所以克雷格接手之前的上一部邦德电影《择日而亡》，简直就是一个笑话，里面有隐形车，还有麦当娜参演，简直就是垃圾，太糟糕了，那是皮尔斯·布鲁斯南的最后一部电影，而克雷格真正扭转了局面，所以他将很难被取代，我想。但他已经把这种风格发挥到了极致，一种非常冷硬的、充满矛盾的邦德形象。他们不得不回到稍微有点罗杰·摩尔风格的路线上去。
Yeah, I would have said so because otherwise it they'll just be doing a poor man's Day, you've seen Kingsman with Colin Firth. No, I haven't I'm not a great man for for bond. It's wonderful It's really good because whenever I go to a bond Bond parody I just really want to be watching a Bond film I don't want to watch some imitation it's not really parody I'd just rather watch Moonraker again I'd say it's more an homage I mean it loves it
是的，我本来也会这么说，因为否则的话，他们就只是在拍廉价版的——你看过科林·费斯主演的《王牌特工》吗？没有，我没看过，我不是个狂热的邦德迷。那部电影太棒了。真的很好，因为每当我去看邦德的恶搞片时，我其实只想看一部邦德电影，我不想看什么模仿之作，它其实算不上恶搞，我宁愿再看一遍《太空城》。我觉得它更像是一种致敬，我的意思是，它热爱
it loves Bond okay it's not taking the piss it's do check it it's really great I loved it I've seen it about ten times
邦德。好吧，它不是在讽刺，真的很棒，去看吧。我太喜欢了，大概看了十遍吧。
and what's your other question which Bond film is the best well again the best or my favourite? So the best is Skyfall. The favourite first. I have two favourites. One is Octopussy.
那你的另一个问题是什么？哪部邦德电影最好？好吧，又是“最好”还是“我最喜欢”？所以最好的是《天幕杀机》。先说最喜欢的。我有两个最喜欢的。一个是《八爪女》。
I love Octopussy. That's the one where he dresses up as a clown, isn't it? He defuses a bomb. There's an eucalyptus bomb in a circus. Yeah, exactly. So you do know your Bond films. Well, I saw all the Roger Moore ones. And you, Dopur.
我太喜欢《八爪女》了。就是他在里面装扮成小丑的那部，对吧？他拆除了一枚炸弹。马戏团里有一枚桉树炸弹。对，完全没错。所以你确实很了解邦德电影。好吧，我看过所有罗杰·摩尔的电影。还有《八爪女》。
Yes. Vijay Vijay Armitraj the tennis player is his local fixer and Bond does this terrible thing when he's made
是的，网球运动员维贾伊·阿姆里特拉吉是他在当地的眼线，邦德做了一件很糟糕的事，当他在赌场赢了
a lot of money in a casino and he gives all this money to his Indian collaborators and says that should keep
很多钱后，他把这些钱都分给了他的印度合作者，并说这些钱足够让他们吃几周的咖喱了。里面有很多经不起时间考验的玩笑，但我一直很喜欢那个，因为
you in curry for a few weeks there's a lot of banter that doesn't really stand the test of time but I always like that because
那是取景于乌代浦的水上宫殿。哦，我知道我们要聊到哪儿了，我后来还在乌代浦加冕了王子呢。你从来没被邀请去拍一部邦德电影吗，汤姆？没有，不过很奇怪，呃……所以我喜欢《八爪女》，但我绝对最喜欢的邦德电影是《生死关头》。那是巫毒题材的。那是巫毒题材的，20世纪70年代初。哦，那是保罗·麦卡特尼演唱主题曲的那部，Wings乐队的。黑人剥削电影。是的，现在看来，
that's set in the lake palace in udai pur oh i know where we're going with this and i then subsequently bowled the crown prince of udai pur yeah you've never been approached to be in a bond film tom no but strange um so i like octopussy but my absolute favorite bond film is live and let die that's voodoo that'soodoo, early 1970s. Oh, that's the Paul Cutley one, Wings. Blaxploitation. Yeah, now that's a film,
坦白自己对《生死关头》有极大的喜爱是有点冒险的，因为这是一部真正经不起时间考验的电影。所以我小时候觉得它绝对迷人、吓人而且完全令人信服，呃，但现在当我观看时，我不禁注意到所有的黑人角色都是阴谋的一部分，而且阴谋里没有一个是白人，其中的巫毒场景可能无法通过年轻观众的审视。那是他跑过
to confess to a great fondness for Live and Let Die is slightly, is risky, because it's a film that really hasn't stood the test of time. So I found it absolutely transfixing as a child and terrifying and completely persuasive um but now when i watch it i can't help noticing that all the black characters are part of the conspiracy and that nobody in the conspiracy is white and the voodoo scenes probably would not pass muster with a with a young audience is that the one where he runs across the
一排鳄鱼的那部吗？是的，他就是。所以简·西摩扮演一个名叫索利泰尔的算命先生，她的超能力取决于她是个处女，而邦德——邦德和她睡了，于是她失去了超能力。非常不幸。呃，他是为了英国才和她睡的吗？是的，他总是为了英格兰，你知道的，正如他经常说的那样。所以去年夏天我看了《生死关头》——在封城期间的一家电影院里，当时人们在放映老电影。我们附近的一家影院在放映《生死关头》，我带我儿子去看了。我环顾了一下周围的座位。
line of crocodiles he does he so jane seymour plays a fortune teller called solitaire whose powers depend on her being a virgin and bond um bond sleeps with her and she loses her powers very unfortunate um is he sleeping with her for britain yeah he's always for england you know as he often as he often says so i saw livernet die last summer um in a cinema during the lockdown when people were screening old films. A cinema near us had Live and Let Die, and I took my son to see it. And I looked along the row.
那是周六下午的场次。我在想，还有哪些悲伤的中年男子带着他们的儿子来看《生死关头》？离我们最近的那个人是——《天幕杀机》的导演萨姆·门德斯和他的儿子。所以基本上电影剩下的时间里，我都一直在想方设法寻找机会，看怎么能在散场时和萨姆·门德斯套近乎、成为朋友，并且争取一个角色。我的策略是，一亮灯就很大声地说：“嗯，挺好的，但不如《天幕杀机》。”你认为它是最好的一部？是的，我想它大概是最好的一部，呃，因为它的
So it was a Saturday afternoon screening. I was thinking, what other sad middle-aged men are there with their sons watching Live and Let Die? And the nearest man to us was uh sam mendez the director of skyfall with his son and so basically i spent the rest of the film trying to think of ways in which i could manufacture becoming friends with sam mendez at the end of getting a role and my strategy was to sort of say very loudly as soon as the lights went up well it's good but it's not as good as skyfall which you're naming it as the best yeah i think it probably is the best um because it's the the
剧本是最聪明的，呃，它是对邦德现象本身思考得最深刻的一部，它有一个极其出色的反派，由哈维尔·巴登饰演，而且它做了一件非常有趣的事——它没有真正传统的邦德女郎。M女士，朱迪·和琪，是主要的女性角色。那是他们最后去了苏格兰的那部吗？是的，在邦德的老家，家族老宅，是的。所以这是一次回归邦德自身过去的旅程，这也是我喜欢的。邦德什么时候会停播？它还会持续多久？我想它还会持续很长时间，真的，我想，只要它还能赚钱。所以每次邦德电影上映时，卫报都会毫不例外地发表社论，说该是杀死詹姆斯·邦德的时候了，他是厌女症患者，是个
script is the cleverest uh it's the it's the most thoughtful about about about the bond phenomenon itself it's got a tremendous villain in um javier bardem and it does a very interesting thing so it doesn't have really a traditional bond girl m judy dench is the main sort of female character is that the one where they end up in scotland they do at bond's old family family home yeah um so it's a sort of journey back into bond's own past um which i like as well when will bond stop how long will it go on for i think it'll continue for quite a long time actually i think um as long as it makes money so every time the bond film comes out the guardian unfailingly runs an op-ed saying it's time for to kill off james bond he's misogynist and it's
冷战遗迹，诸如此类的话。呃，但接着你看看票房收入，你会想，你知道的，你可以对着虚空尽情嚎叫，但只要它还在赚钱，永恒制作公司——也就是制作它的公司——就会源源不断地把它拍下去。它基本上是英国唯一的超级英雄系列电影。是的，我想是的。呃，但汤姆，换个角度来看，这实际上是几乎唯一一个非美国的超级英雄系列电影。我想美国观众会接受、会认可一个英国超级英雄，
cold war relic and all this stuff um but then you look at the box office returns and you think you know you can howl into the void as much as you like but as long as it's making money eon productions which is the company that makes it are going to continue churning them out and it's basically the only british kind of superhero franchise yes yes i suppose it is um but actually a different way of putting that, Tom, is it's virtually the only non-American superhero franchise. And I think American audiences will take, will accept a British superhero,
但如果他是德国人，他们就不会接受，对吧？我是说，想象一下如果他是比利时人。比利时秘密特工，你知道的，让-卢克什么的。好吧，他们在《星际迷航》里有让-卢克·皮卡尔。但我的意思是，我知道他是英国人。帕特里克·斯图尔特住在埃文河畔斯特拉特福。这其实不太……
but they wouldn't accept him if he was German, let's say, would they? I mean, imagine if he was Belgian. Belgian Secret Service, you know. Jean-Luc, you know. Well, they had Jean-Luc Picard in Star Trek. But I mean, I know he was English. I mean, Patrick Stutes lives in Stratford-upon-Avon. I mean, it's not very...
我知道，我知道。我想挑战在于——我们在整个过程中一直在暗示的——一个扎根于50年代标准的保守主义者的势利、种族主义和性别歧视中的人物，能否在完全不同的时代延续下去？我想这就是丹尼尔·克雷格所做的一切。是的，丹尼尔·克雷格已经证明了你确实可以做到这一点，是的。呃，邦德不需要变得“觉醒”（woke），
I know, I know. I guess the challenge is, can, which we've hinted at throughout the whole thing, is can a figure who is rooted in the snobbery and the racism and the sexism of someone who is reactionary by the standards of the 50s yeah last into a very different age and i guess that's what daniel craig has been about yeah and daniel craig has shown that you can do that actually yeah um you don't bond doesn't need to be woke as it were i
我的意思是，邦德只需要做到——不是种族主义者，不具攻击性，是的，不具攻击性。而且邦德——既然这个角色一直有点保守，我认为他稍微带点保守色彩并不是什么问题。所以在《金手指》里，肖恩·康纳利，1964年，肖恩·康纳利对披头士乐队很不客气。是的，他说，是的，你应该戴着耳机听他们的歌。是的，戴着耳罩，完全没错。喝着唐培里侬香槟，而且没有冰镇。完全没错。
mean bond merely needs to be um not not a racist not offensive yeah not offensive and and bond but since the character has always been slightly reactionary i don't think it's a problem for him still to be slightly reactionary so in goldfinger, Sean Connery, 1964, Sean Connery is disobliging about the Beatles. Yes, he says, yeah, you should listen to them with earphones. Yeah, with earmuffs, exactly. Drinking Dom Perignon, not chilled. Exactly.
所以在这方面，邦德一直有点像个老头子。所以他不需要显得很酷。因为那是伊恩·弗莱明，对吧？是的，因为那是伊恩·弗莱明，但也是因为很大程度上——因为你知道谁会去看邦德电影？我的意思是，比如十几岁的男孩和像我这样的中年男人。所以在某种程度上，我不认为它需要改变，它拥有一个行之有效的品牌，而且那个观众群体并没有消失。我的意思是，那个观众群体会改变和进化，但它不会消失。
So Bond has always been a bit of an old man in that respect. So he doesn't need to be cool. Because that's Ian Fleming, right? Yeah, because it's Ian Fleming, but also because a lot because a lot of because you know who goes to see Bond films I mean sort of teenage boys and middle-aged men like me um so in a way I don't really think it needs to it has a brand that works and though that audience is not going away I mean that audience will change and evolve but it's not going to disappear okay Okay, well, I think that's James Bond done. Great.
好吧。好吧，我想詹姆斯·邦德的话题就到这里。太棒了。想要阅读更多内容的听众，我推荐多米尼克的书《伟大的英国梦想工厂》，其中有一章关于邦德的精彩内容。所以去看新电影，然后读读多米尼克的书吧。我们显然会回来，大概在周四，带来更多历史主题的播客内容。我们到时候见。
People who want to read more, I would recommend Dominic's book, The Great British Dream Factory, which has a fantastic chapter on Bond. So go and see the new film and then read Dominic's book. We will be back, obviously, probably on Thursday with more historically themed podcastery. We will see you then.
拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及进入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。